yanis c'était le prénom du mineur décédé
dans cet accident
une marche blanche était organisée par
ses proches dimanche après midi pour lui
rendre un dernier hommage
le cortège a convergé vers le lieu du
drame
romain delville en tête de cortège la
famille de yanis sa tante sa soeur et sa
mère qui a répété les appels à
l'apaisement dans le quartier pour la
mémoire de son fils mort à seize ans
j'arrive pas à croire
chaque fois j'ai dit mon fils il va
rentrer eva toqué c'est le moment que le
matin la nuit je les fais je les fais
pas biseau pour lui souhaiter bonne nuit
m'a pas souhaiter bonne nuit et le matin
qui me fait pas bisous le moment qu'ils
se réveillent mme dit bonjour maman ito
c'est là que j'ai commencé à croire
comme quoi on chie c'est parti parce que
là c'est vraiment très dur pour
accompagner la famille dans la marche
blanche 400 personnes dont beaucoup de
jeunes
quelques pancartes de soutien et une
volonté ferme
que la justice fasse toute la lumière
sur les circonstances qui ont conduit à
la mort de l'adolescent est également
qu'on soit avec une voiture et sans peur
de leurs premiers taux d'alcool
trop comme ça on regarde déjà on a perdu
un sac à main et tout c'est vraiment
touchant chrono et pour sa famille c'est
pas parce qu'on ne fait pas un peu
bronzé qu'on cherche la merde
j'espère que ça va pas se reproduire une
atmosphère de deuil
un esprit de recueillement pour ses
habitants unis dans la peine la mère
endeuillée dont les mots ont ému le
cortège a rappelé à la fin de la marche
blanche toute la confiance qu'elle a en
la justice